by the way Jason is one of the creators
of hit him with the hind correct yes I
started just being really obnoxious with
it every time John with wartime John was
trying to sneak out it not sneak just
leave in a nonchalant way not to be
noticed turn the woman gun you would
scream out hit him with me John hit him
with the hyeme and the other week saying
to John go hit him with all that huh oh
go go bring that [ __ ] personality
John as you have documented you hate
this it's such nonsense is such
ridiculous nonsense that just a hidden
with the hide and that gets him angry
and it just amuses the crap out of it I
never should have let on that I cared
about it because once I did Jason
immediately sinks his teeth into it
because that's what Jason does you're
angry really no I know Jason means it in
good fun but I hate people who get off
on just annoying the [ __ ] out of me
don't you think
Jason is protected by the work
environment so he can be a bit of a
wiseass and yeah in the real world you
would just clobber him it'll be the end
if we weren't at work if he would have
been hit by the hind well I hate seeing
two pear-shaped men fight like you don't
like Jason do you I don't like when
Jason does this yeah I don't think
you're a fan Jason knows how I feel
about him we've had discussion look
complicated Jon who denies that this is
good from John got a big write-up a few
weeks ago on some big sports website
yeah and the headline didn't use jump
the shark which had which is all-time
but John doesn't want to be known for
hit him with the high be known for
hitting with the high but big headline
John is hitting them with the high just
cuz it's world just cuz it works for you
doesn't mean it works for him he knows
that he doesn't need that he say he
doesn't want he doesn't want a headline
that says John is hitting them with the
heart he loves it is Jason correcting in
some level you like this no right he's
just doing it to stir it up and gate
because he's very good at getting under
people's skin and I'm not the only
person on this panel I think who would
attest to that here's a hit him with the
hind side
hit him with a high